hello and welcome to this video playing
anti-drone I don't know what he does
against you for I usually have some
wacky Dutch defenses against him let's
go for a change of pace yeah playing the
classic line yonder in the dragon I
don't know any sharp lines so I'm
playing playing this ok so it seems that
this is not very testing especially
considering how quickly bashed out those
moves but it's 95 problem I know maybe
just pawn to d4 and well this looks very
weakly but that the speed with the dirty
played the mood to suggest that this is
wow wow wow I have a hard time to
believe that this is this is great
anyway ok um he wants to go 94 I guess
on on a bishop see form you should see
for comes yeah maybe
I've got this activity okay I think I'll
start with taking anyway Bishop c4 94 I
can like a lot to cover that amazingly
just taking taking you for you take some
place rookie one that's not helping
thank you for him it's an annoying move
94 I go nite b5 there's night be four
then I have 93 okay maybe this it's
interesting that pawn structure looks
absolutely terrible but it's got this
activity going
night sit through this Bishop is six I
guess you might him he might might maybe
could have played it anyway
yeah interesting I mean he seems they
could he really yeah couldn't we could
play like that it wasn't bad quite sure
how I'm playing here now cannot so
easily develop
yeah because always attacked see 395 I
guess Wow very difficult this for me
it's difficult probably have to do
something like that it doesn't really
look great but maybe have to yeah okay
taking it's not possible I Scott 93
coming
Wow tough
okay to I didn't quite expect okay let's
take that it's got 93 then okay shoot ok
I didn't see anything today Wow
all kind of a straight in Game time
warning be blunt with that that a poor
Ned I didn't didn't didn't take any
advantage of it so what is this is good
he straps my Rick ah what a game oh my
goodness what a what an atrocious game
by me wow this is one of the worst
really okay come on haha white resigns
it was that sucked I mean it was just a
tired a disgusting game Jim and this is
really supposed to work maybe it is it
looks weird with this pawn structure but
he's got this active play with with with
with 94 always or night before and so
this is what I did and maybe it's
already wrong yeah my computer likes
black it wants to play this immediately
maybe it's better not to trade queens
now 94 we should be 3s posing a problem
yeah the one difference is that that I'm
controlling this now with the Queen and
I divorce downright bad he has to go
here never is very active him
is very active yeah yeah I'm worse I'm
just worse in this position and rook
takes you four i blundered actually
which it didn't didn't play I thought it
was just a very bad game bye bye bye
white yeah I'm very struggling he just
blundered that move but it didn't even
matter that much yeah I went here which
loses but i think and i thought this
losses as well but i probably have to go
here you have to do this try to hang on
here even though this is also not a good
good game I just an atrocious game now
let my rope trap it's just wow
disgusting yeah I really have to get
back together yeah that's really bad I
mean I don't know this kind of position
well but I shouldn't really felt it fall
apart yeah after this I Bishop c4 is a
lot better really because 94 is no
option no yeah I don't get corny needed
at all which is not good he's just far
too active I mean the pawn structure is
terrible and I've got two bishops but I
cannot coordinate the position just too
too badly too badly develop oh ok thanks
for watching